Is there...
...any circumstance...
...more terrifying...
... than when a child goes missing?
It's a horrible situation.
Every parent's worst nightmare.
But what if I told you...
...another local teen went missing.
Her name is Drea Spivey.
Drea's disappearance...
...has never been covered by a single...
...news outlet.
I aim to find them.
And the people...
...responsible for taking them away.
Drea makes eleven total, all
reported  missing...
...in Oakland.
What happened to Drea...
... could happen to any one of
your kids.
I get how important independence
is at your age, but independence in Oakland...
...can require a deal with the devil.
The police...
...ain't doin' enough.
I'm pushing as hard as I can...
...to get more resources for Drea.
While in office...
...I championed...
...a strong police department.
Please pardon the interruption.
My daughter is missing too!
Say her name!
...Say her name! Say her
name! Say her name!
We think Drea...
...may have received some gifts.
To my office now!
I don't think it's a good idea to
be playing detective with your students.
I think it might be something more.
More?
Like what?
If you think it...
...has a chance to bring her home...
...do it.
My name is Poppy Scoville.
This story...
...could ruin my career.
It's the truth.
Not a story.
Get in.
What the hell is your end game?
People show fragments...
...they want the world to see.
I wish I could trust you.
Did you ever?
What happens when you dig deeper?
I hope you'll follow me into this world.
No matter where it leads.